[Music]
on this Tuesday night some optimism as
inflation cools we're not out of the
woods yet why the pace of price Rises is
slowing and what it signals it's
constantly in the back of our minds it's
getting crazy
breaking news Fox News agrees to pay
almost a billion dollars to settle a
lawsuit the truth matters
lies have consequences the dramatic
conclusion to one of the most watched
media trials in decades
friends in warm places questions about a
Trudeau family vacation to a luxury
Caribbean Resort
bus pulling a championship out of the
bag she found it very nice good find
meet the Canadian teenager making
history Atop The Scrabble World
[Music]
Rebel National with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with some positive signs about the
cost of living in Canada the annual
inflation rate fell again in March the
lowest it's been since August of 2021.
inflation dropped to 4.3 percent down
from 5.2 percent in February gas prices
are down 13 percent from March of 2022
but mortgage interest costs they Rose at
the fastest Pace on record last month up
26.4 percent from a year ago grocery
prices are still Rising too though at a
slower Pace 9.7 percent in March
compared to 10.6 percent the month
before Heather urich's West has our top
story on what these indicators point to
with 12 and 15 year old boys Lindsay
Kendrick is spending a lot of money
lately on food
they are eating like constantly like all
the time and week after week
the price of those groceries continues
to rise I find like the meats are like
very expensive and like produce and then
just like fresh uh Fresh Foods is just
very expensive it's just really
impossible to kind of um stay ahead and
just on top of everything the youngs
have seven living at home two parents
four kids and a baby who arrived just
last week the family food bill has never
been so steep last year I was actually
tracking around this time so it was
between 700 to 900 a month and this
literally has doubled the food prices
are still high they're still at about
nine percent year-over-year growth as of
the March data print according to
economists there are signals that relief
is on the way the country's inflation
rate has dipped five consecutive times
and while it's still higher than the
target of two percent the cooling means
the bank of Canada's interest rate hikes
are working but we're not out of the
woods yet but it will take time to bring
us back towards that level of price
growth that's consistent with economic
stability and a more comfortable quality
of life
unfortunately for families like the
Kendricks it's likely to be a few more
months of escalating price pain the
youngs worry how they'll cover their
Rising costs it's constantly in the back
of our minds like
what are we gonna have to are we gonna
have to sell our you know our trailer or
anything just to you know survive it's
it's getting crazy already Canada's
fight against inflation far from one
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary
in the U.S a dramatic development in a
defamation case Fox News has settled a
billion dollar lawsuit over lies it
aired during the 2020 presidential
election the news emerged just before
opening arguments began in court Fox
News agreed to pay
787 million dollars to Dominion voting
systems it was seeking 1.6 billion
dollars in compensation alleging Fox
knowingly defamed it with baseless
claims the election was rigged against
Donald Trump Jackson prosco has the
details of this massive settlement and
what it means Jackson
well Donna simply put Fox's dishonesty
about Dominion voting systems has cost
it this massive amount of money as you
mentioned
787.5 million dollars this agreement was
reached in the very early stages of the
trial a jury had just been seated in the
case they were ready to go in a Delaware
Courthouse but this was always going to
be a tough case for Fox because the
judge had already ruled that fox had
made false statements about Dominion as
part of backing Donald Trump's lies
about the 2020 election the question the
jury would have faced is whether Fox
acted with malice in spreading those
lies in announcing the settlement
Dominion's lawyers said this is proof
that lies have consequences
fox has admitted to telling lies about
Dominion
that caused enormous damage to my
company our employees and the customers
that we serve
nothing can ever make up for that
now the settlement means that Fox's CEO
Rupert Murdoch and big all-nair names
like Tucker Carlson and Sean Hannity
will not have to testify in court in a
statement Fox News said we acknowledge
the Court's ruling finding certain
claims about Dominion to be false they
go on to say that the settlement
reflects Fox's continued commitment to
what they say are the highest
journalistic standards Donna neither
side will say if there are additional
terms to the settlement but at this
point it seems unlikely that there will
be any on-air apology or retraction by
Fox and we should point out Fox News
still faces an additional defamation
lawsuit by another voting systems
company called smartmatic
Ray Jackson prosco in Washington thanks
after the arrests in the U.S related to
what the FBI call a secret Chinese
police station in the heart of New York
City what's happening with similar
investigations here in Canada the Human
Rights group Safeguard Defenders has
exposed what it says is a network of
dozens of suspected Chinese outposts
around the world including in Canada and
the U.S and now two Americans have been
charged with conspiring to act as agents
for the Chinese government and there's
evidence they may have a connection to
Canada our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson is with me Mercedes where do
things stand with the investigations
here
well Donna that's a great question and
it's one that we put to the Royal
Canadian Mounted Police they have
confirmed that the investigations that
they've talked about previously are
still ongoing and active but they say
that because of that they can't say much
else here's what we do know the RCMP
posted Cruisers outside of the known
locations of these so-called police
stations that was to show presence but
beyond that we don't know very much
including whether or not the stations in
question have simply been relocated to a
new location also of interest in the U.S
documents we read the affidavit the FBI
says that they raided the station in New
York and that was fairly productive for
evidence of for them we don't know
whether or not the RCMP have rated
locations here in Canada to get similar
kinds of evidence the RCMP have said
that they are looking at potential
criminal charges in fact when I spoke to
the interim commissioner he said they
were looking at the possibility of
harassment charges but Canada doesn't
have a foreign agent's ready industry
like the United States so this would not
be an identical charge experts here say
that a foreign agent's registry would
help but a former ceases agent who we
spoke to said there are laws on the
books the RCMP could get started on now
but that we tend to be behind on these
kinds of Investigations we don't need to
reinvent the wheel in terms of
legislation I think it's just a matter
of our national police force
are much further behind in terms of
experience and history and dealing with
this type of nuanced threat Mercedes
what about the evidence of a Canadian
connection to the two men charged in New
York
well Donna in this affidavit you can see
that it says that there was a photograph
found on one of the accused cell phones
and it says that it showed an opening
ceremony with the five countries to
First establish overseas Police Service
locations and that among those
individuals depicted in the photographs
were Association presidents from Spain
France Canada and the Netherlands we
haven't seen that photo and we don't
know the identity of the individual in
it or whether or not the RCMP have seen
it either but it certainly opens a lot
more questions about those ongoing
investigations and where they might go
okay Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
the federal government in Canada's
largest public sector Union are counting
down to one of the biggest strikes in
Canadian history if a deal is not
reached by 9 pm Eastern tonight the
public service Alliance of Canada says
its members will walk Mackenzie gray is
with me Mackenzie her negotiations going
right down to the wire they certainly
are Donna the federal government and the
public service Alliance of Canada are
still at the table right now trying to
bang out a deal but there was some
optimism earlier today from the Prime
Minister on how the talks are going
I think it's really important that
Canadians can continue to rely on the
kinds of services they need from the
federal government and that's why both
parties at the table are negotiating
extremely diligently and with a lot of
intensity to try and resolve this so the
biggest issue right now is the union
wanting more money they want a 13.5
increase over the next three years the
feds say that they'll give nine percent
over three years but it's not just money
Donna the union has outlined at least a
dozen other issues the biggest might be
right now for federal employees to be
able to work from home and that's
something liberals have really pushed
back against but if a strike does happen
155 000 civil servants will be impacted
but expect that the federal government
will deem thousands of them to be
essential to help keep some Services
going but even then a strike would lead
to interruptions at 23 different
departments including the passport
office where processing would be
severely limited immigration
applications would basically grind to a
halt and the CRA might be slow in
issuing tax returns and let's let the
union to warn Donna that folks should
file their taxes ASAP
okay and Mackenzie if they do walk what
might the picket lines look like
tomorrow yeah well I mentioned one of
the key issues for the union is working
from home and the unions made it clear
that their members can't strike from
home so there could be some delays for
Canadians on their way to work tomorrow
they'll be about 250 pick locations
across the country as you'd expect
there's going to be a big one here on
Parliament Hill but also Trudeau airport
in Montreal City Hall in Toronto Canada
Place in Edmonton some of the places
where people will be and if your union
member shows up they'll get 75 a day in
strike pay and if the union gets the
tens of thousands of members they hope
they will they might blow through their
strike fund pretty quickly in about two
weeks and Donna that makes a prospect of
a protracted walkout less likely all
right Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thanks
police in Winnipeg have made a tragic
Discovery and are asking for public help
they found the partial remains of a
woman's body along the bank of the Red
River and want help in identifying her
police say the partial remains were
found Saturday officers don't believe
the discovery is related to any other
investigations in the city the woman is
believed to be over 20 years old of
unknown ethnicity she was between five
and five foot five with a slight build
short dark hair and both ears double
pierced investigators say it's unclear
how long the body had been there
crime scene was approximately 3 000
meters in length it was searched am I
going to stand up here today and say
that we discovered everything no I'm not
police say they intend to conduct a more
detailed investigation including DNA
testing
there are questions tonight about a
vacation prime minister Justin Trudeau
and his family took they went to Jamaica
last Christmas and stayed in the Villa
of a longtime family friend who has also
donated money to the Pierre Elliot
Trudeau Foundation the winter getaway
cost taxpayers tens of thousands of
dollars most of that for security and
staff and though the ethics commissioner
cleared the trip before they left the
prime minister's judgment is again being
called into question by his political
opponents turia isri reports
Prospect Estates is a luxury Villa in
Jamaica with sweeping ocean views that
don't come cheap the rooms go for as
much as nine thousand dollars a night
the Trudeau's spent their Christmas
vacation there 160 thousand dollars of
taxpayer expenses for the Prime Minister
going to go down to the private Villa
luxurious Villa of a super rich Trudeau
Foundation donor Mr Speaker our family
have been good friends with this family
for about 50 years and as always we work
with the ethics commissioner to make
sure that all rules are followed the
Caribbean getaway cost around 162
thousand dollars most of it for security
and Personnel a hundred and fifteen
thousand for the RCMP 33 000 to the
Royal Canadian Air Force and 13 000 for
privy Council staff it's just another
example of a prime minister that doesn't
understand the realities of everyday
Canadians the vacation home is owned by
the Green family as first reported by
Radio Canada Lord Alexander green spoke
at Pierre Trudeau's funeral the office
of the ethics commissioner cleared the
trip but won't say whether it knew about
a 2021 donation by the Green family to
the Trudeau foundation and of course he
stays with a friend who's donated to the
Trudeau Foundation because he's so
independent from that Foundation less
than a week ago the president CEO an
entire board of directors at the Trudeau
Foundation resigned following
Revelations a Chinese businessman with
ties to Beijing donated two hundred
thousand dollars to the charity the
prime minister's office says he paid the
equivalent of a commercial airline
ticket for himself and his family and
that this is standard practice but this
isn't the first time Trudeau's vacation
choices have been called into question I
took responsibility Trudeau apologized
for violating the conflict of interest
act after a 270 thousand dollar trip to
the AGA Khan's Private Island in 2016.
you have to make sure that there is no
perception where you think that some
wealthy people and dividola have
privileged access it's still not clear
whether Trudeau paid for the
accommodation in a tropical getaway his
opponents say make him look out of touch
at home tariya esri Global News Ottawa
in Sudan there are reports a 24-hour
ceasefire between the country's two
rival generals is not holding
heard across cartoon fighting between
Sudan's armed forces and a paramilitary
group is now in its fourth day as the
powerful military factions battle for
control millions of Sudanese people are
caught on the crossfire at least 270
people have been killed that's according
to the World Health Organization the U.N
Aid Chief says they've received reports
humanitarian workers are being attacked
in some cases even sexually assaulted
the incredible Story of Survival coming
up a mother speaks out as her son
recovers from a shooting plus sitting
Idle No More this Russian plane has been
sitting in Toronto where it's headed now
the mother of a teenager who was shot
twice by a homeowner after mistakenly
ringing the wrong doorbell in Kansas
City last week says she doesn't know how
her son managed to survive
because if you get shot at that close of
a range and the city said that and the
doctor don't understand how then I don't
understand how
sixteen-year-old Ralph yarl is now
recovering at home surrounded by a team
of medical professionals he was shot in
the head and the arm his mother who's a
nurse says he's doing well you're always
picking up his younger twin brothers at
a friend's house Thursday night but
accidentally went to the wrong address
and while he was standing there his
brothers didn't run outside but he got a
couple of bullets in his body instead of
a couple of twins coming up out and
giving him a hug
the white homeowner an 84 year old man
accused of shooting yarl has been
charged with assault in the first degree
in armed criminal action
in rural Upstate New York another
shooting this one fatal a homeowner is
charged with second-degree murder after
a 20-year-old woman was shot and killed
when the car she was in turned into the
wrong driveway on Saturday night Kevin
Monahan is accused of firing Two Shots
from his porch Kalyn Gillis who is in
the passenger seat of the car died
investigators don't believe the group
had any previous interaction with
Monahan the woman's lawyer says there
was no reason for him to feel threatened
dueling visits ahead Vladimir Putin and
Vladimir zelanski meet with troops in
Ukraine
this huge Russian cargo plane grounded
at Toronto Pearson Airport may not be
taking up space for much longer
Ukraine's prime minister says it's being
confiscated along with other Russian
assets to be used to help in the war
effort the plane has been sitting idle
for more than a year after delivering a
shipment of covid-19 tests
the U.S journalists arrested on
Espionage charges in Russia appeared in
a Moscow courtroom today his appeal to
be freed from pre-trial detention was
rejected it's the first time he's been
seen in public in weeks while Street
Journal reporter Evan gershowitz stood
inside a glass cage with his arms folded
appearing calm even cracking a smile at
times the 31 year old was detained March
29 Accused by Russian officials of
allegedly trying to obtain classified
information he has pleaded not guilty
the Russian President Vladimir Putin has
made his second visit to war-torn
Ukraine it's unclear when exactly he was
there he met with troops at the military
headquarters in hersan and luhansk which
are both partly occupied by Russian
forces Putin also attended a military
command meeting and saw the National
Guard
foreign
President Vladimir zielinski was in
eastern Ukraine wearing his signature
combat gear he addressed troops and
handed out Awards he called it an honor
to be there and he thanked the soldiers
for their service zielinski also made a
surprise visit to a hospital in the
Donetsk region to Rally troops who were
recovering from injuries
he has a way with words next the Toronto
teenager who made history with her
Scrabble skills
[Music]
it feels like there's not much new to
discover in the world and then
scientists stumble on this a pristine
previously unknown coral reef off
Ecuador's Galapagos Islands it's about
two kilometers long about 400 meters
deep and has an abundance of marine life
the coral reef is believed to be several
thousand years old Ecuador expanded the
Marine reserve around the Galapagos
Islands last year
well they say the most dangerous part of
playing Scrabble is that someone could
lose an eye
okay bad jokes aside it is a board game
that's endured for decades and a whole
new generation is playing it now in fact
in Ontario High School student has just
become an international Scrabble
Champion our Mike drolet spoke with her
about her rare gift for words
Mal Brook Mal Brook
as far as spelling competitions go these
scripts spelling bee is the Super Bowl
it's a flashy big prize TV spectacle
it'll play there wow then there's the
Scrabble championships which is watched
online by hundreds yeah it's a fairly
Niche uh game but I don't really mind
that
I I don't really think that people in
the Scrabble Community seek more
recognition well that ends today here at
least because of a 17 year old
torontonian who went 8-0 to reach the
finals of the North American
championships this is just the best of
one Ultimate Showdown for that title
Ruth Lee was 11 when she first set eyes
on Scrabble a game that rewards those
who can remember rarely used words a
perfect fit as it turns out for Lee in
the finals she immediately flexed her
Scrabble muscles starting off with feces
a word you may only ever see used on a
Scrabble board that describes a
belligerent Mongrel dog and she was only
getting warmed up like in one of the
first moves of my finals game I played
fogy I don't even know what that one
means but it's kind of a strange looking
word No Stranger Than the geometric term
fastening or the currencies guineas and
dinar words she never uses in
conversation but pulled from her
Scrabble memory banks very nice good
find and when time ran out she won she
shook hands smiled collected her
thousand dollar prize and returned home
with a unique talent to add to her
University applications alongside her
true passion robotics you see in her
spare time she goes to the Holland blue
review kids Rehabilitation Hospital the
largest of its kind in Canada to help
kids develop problem-solving skills
through robotics I just really want to
spread that to my community and to other
children like her dominance in Scrabble
she does it with little Fanfare leave
the accolades to the spelling bee the
true Wordsmith is right here microlight
Global News Toronto
so understated that is global national
for this Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's your candidate is the Ottawa
new Edinburgh Club Boathouse in Ontario
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]